hi i'm such a fan of you thank you
i'm a fan of yours it's rare though like
i feel like when actors are that
talented where you do you can be funny
you can be serious you can it's all the
emotions i love all your movies they're
so different it's cool you just got
right to it thank you very much
my daughter called me today who's at our
ranch right now and she said oh my god
you're doing kelly clarkson yeah oh my
god like you're cool oh like you're
really
cool that's like so now i'm cool oh that
was like me wait that was me with my
kids um they're five and seven and
ariana grande they were like you know
her oh yeah and i was like sure okay
i do she's awesome but i'm cultured 3 28
3 and one oh my god they're so that's
very far that's kind of cool though yeah
but i got that one thing like on the
street where they're like grandpa and i
go no no no no no really
no i feel like it's so normal now it's
like it is kind of i guess not is it
normal now i don't know i get i don't
know we're in the entertainment industry
so i feel like it's normal ah that's
tough yeah i'm just saying yeah i don't
feel like it's maybe normal like no it's
part of the contract that you signed you
have to have babies after 15.
hey i waited until i was 30 to start
creating and yes and i'm glad i did
because i said procreating yeah you did
i could call it something else if you
want totally it's daytime i was trying
to be like family friendly no but i
waited and i'm glad because i had a life
yeah like i enjoyed my 20s yeah i had my
first when i was 20.
19 when she was pregnant 20 25 50 and
52. and then i'll do 67
i've
i like a man with a plan it's nice
[Music]